I know this is very how does have a
Riley this is a fabulous question how
does the earth have earthquakes
well nominally or this is just thinking
about the first way the earth is made of
these big slabs of land that move around
on the lava or magma which is what
geologists call that molten block when
it's underground magma and they move
around and they bump into each other
four and a half billion years ago when
these objects formed out of dust it is
interesting to notice wryly that not
only is the dust on a bookshelf being
pulled down by the earth but the dust is
ever so slightly pulling the earth up
there attracting each other it's really
it's quite a thing to get your head
around as we say so the earth was formed
from dust it came like this and started
spinning then that compressing it got it
got hot and now these pieces of land are
bouncing off each other so the ocean
sits on top of plates of land the ocean
is on top of solid stuff you may not
have thought about that but if the ocean
is relatively shallow compared to how
deep the earth is how big the earth is
so along this line that's one way we get
earth with earthquakes right now humans
are causing earthquakes in North
American Midwest friend of mine lives in
Oklahoma and what we've done is drill so
many holes into the crust into the earth
to get to oil and gas that we're
actually allowing these much smaller
pieces of the Earth's crust the outer
layer to shift around a little bit and
that's also causing what are just like
earthquakes it's really a remarkable
thing and I remind you Riley earthquakes
don't kill people
buildings kill people so what we do now
is we design buildings that can stand an
earthquake and if you're in a I've been
in several earthquakes I'm fine
if you're in a building and it's a big
earthquake try to get outside
this is what we recommend and so I hope
that in your lifetime here for example
United States all our buildings are made
strong enough earthquakes all our
bridges everything I hope we can pull
that off because we understand it now
when I was a kid right when I was your
age this idea of tectonic plates
tectonics a Greek word for builder for
build the earth is built of these
tectonic plates that was still
controversial the people didn't
altogether agree on it and it started in
1800s with his first name Karl Wegner
saw where South America seemed to fit
into Africa and it sort of does and with
really compelling evidence he found was
the same fossils in South America that
you find in Africa at the same level the
same layers of rock existed on both
exist on both continents and he went hey
man check it out
I paraphrase because it was German but
that led to a whole bunch of discoveries
that prove that the main idea in all
geology is tectonic plates and by some
of them by the way some of the evidence
I mean was done by submarines in world
war ii trying to sneak across the north
atlantic like between the underwater
mountains
it's very cool so tectonic plates allow
the shifting of the earth's surface
which causes earthquakes on a much
shallower level if you drill enough
holes in the ground and set off and
pressurize enough places you can also
get earthquakes they're just part of
life Riley it's part of living on the
earth it's cool
[Music]